[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thank
you for joining us today.
My name does is Navneet Joneja.
I lead product management for
App Engine and Compute Engine
at Google.
And today, we're here to share
how Google builds applications,
what that means in terms of
the capabilities we provide
to our customers in
the Cloud Platform,
and finally, what that means
in terms of the benefits
you can get from our
platform as a user.
So what you see on
the screen right now
is, literally, a page
from our history.
It's the first infrastructure
build we received as Google.
Now back in the day,
building applications
started with buying, what
was back then very expensive,
hardware and deploying
it and managing it.
And quite frankly, the
tools available to do that
were quite terrible.
And we didn't think
we could build
the company we wanted to
build with the technology that
existed back in the day.
For example, the
conventional wisdom back then
was that in order to
build a very highly
reliable application,
you started
with the most reliable
hardware you could find.
So let's say you start with
a piece of hardware which
has a mean time between
failure of 10 years.
That means you
expect, on average,
that device will fail
once every 10 years.
Now you take 100,000
of those devices,
and you put them
in a data center.
The system you've
just built actually
has a mean time between
failure of one hour.
In other words, you can expect
that on average, every hour,
something in that
system is failing.
So no matter how reliable
your hard way is,
hardware is not the path
to reliable applications.
It's really software.
But that was only
half of the picture.
It turns out that even though
hardware and infrastructure was
really expensive back then,
and has gotten a lot cheaper
over time.
Even then, the scarce
resource was not actually
compute resources,
it was our people.
And specifically, the time
and energy of our engineers
who were building and operating,
and keeping Google reliable.
And so the more time
they had to spend
on deploying applications and
building servers, and keeping
them up and running,
the less time they
had to spend on building Google.
And so in order to
maximize Google's growth,
we had to maximize the
growth and productivity
of our engineers.
And so we had to make the
most of that scarce resource.
So what was our solution?
Well really, three things.
The first thing was, instead
of reacting to failure--
we knew we had to
plan for failure,
we knew we had to expect
that things would fail,
and we had to build
systems that could
handle failure transparently.
The second thing was to
take everything we learned,
and we learned a lot, because
we made mistakes a lot,
and encode that into
everything we built.
So those software
and platforms that
took the best that we'd
learned in building operating
Google at scale, and make that
available to all our engineers
as a force multiplier.
Because every time they
use this proven technology,
they were benefiting from
all the accumulated learning
of the engineers who'd
come before them.
And then finally, to
make all this happen,
we had to make investments
at all layers of the stack.
Starting with the design
of our data centers.
And all the way up to a high
level platforms and software
that many engineers use
to build applications.
Now, we had to do
all this ourselves
because back then, these
tools didn't exist, right?
We have to just
build from scratch.
We had to figure out what
worked and build these platforms
for our own use.
And along the way, we wrote
white papers about many
of these subjects.
We talked about MapReduce, we
talked about the Google File
System, we talked about Dremel.
Many pieces of core
technology we were building,
in terms of software and the
platforms we were building,
we actually talked about
in terms-- very publicly--
in terms of the white
papers we wrote.
But that is only half
the picture, right?
Half of what we learned
wasn't just the patterns,
the software, the technology
that was going to work for us.
It was also how we
operate those things
at scale, how we make sure
that those things work really
well when they're
being, when they're
serving large
amounts of traffic.
And if you want to get
the most of the benefit
of our experience, the
best way to do that
is to use the Google
Cloud platform.
So to talk more about
specifically what we learned,
some of the patterns we
think work really well.
And how we really build
applications at Google.
I'd like to invite Joe
Beda, one of our architects,
to the Cloud platform.
Joe?
JOE BEDA: Thanks, Navneet.
And that was
actually me up their.
Navneet stole that picture and
kind of surprised me with that.
So I want to give you a
little bit of an idea of what
it's like to be a
Google engineer.
What your first
week at Google looks
like as you start
learning about what has,
sort of, evolved as the
internal Google platform.
And one of the things
to realize here
is that the Google
Cloud Platform really
is the internal
Google Cloud Platform.
We're exposing the
exact same tools
that we use internally
to you to use.
And we're continuing to expose
more and more of those tools.
So you're going to see
more coming from the Cloud
platform in the months to come.
So when we-- I mean
so the-- you know,
we view these
things as a toolbox
as sort of flexible tools
that you can bring to bear.
And we're breaking
those things down along
for the purposes of this
talk around compute, storage,
networking, and then
sort of services and glue
that really bind all
of this stuff together.
And one of the things
to keep in mind
is that you can use these
tools and these building blocks
in a whole bunch
of different ways.
So you can use them in
well understood patterns,
like we do at Google.
Things like MapReduce.
Or the way that we'll
build a tree of services
to actually do a query,
where you start at a route
and it distributes the
query, collects the results,
and then distills that back up.
Very common architectural
pattern at Google.
But if those things don't
work for you, if those well
understood and
proven patterns, you
can go off and build
your own solutions
using your own architecture.
And so this flexibility
of Building Blocks,
which has really made our
platform stand the test of time
as Google has grown and moved
from doing things like Search
to doing things
like Gmail and Apps.
Now let's dive into
Compute a little bit.
When we look at Compute, one
of the things that Google tries
very hard, and sort of is
necessary for us to do,
is to really avoid snowflakes.
And so the idea of a
snowflake is, so you know,
you want to deploy a service.
So you get a server, you log
in, you install some stuff,
you install your application.
You're done.
Woohoo.
Invoice your customer,
you're done, right?
But now, let's say that you
have to do 100 of those.
Or now let's say that
it's a big application,
you need to scale
that thing out.
Well that's where
things get complicated.
And if you do that all
by hand you'll find,
oh server number 2 is always a
little bit flakey, let me go in
and fix that guy.
So that's a snowflake.
That's a unique server that
has its own unique problems
that you have to deal with.
We've built a ton of
tools and techniques
to be able to manage
things at scale automation,
so that we actually
avoid the situation where
you have these special cases.
And this applies not only
at the infrastructure level,
at making sure that the
individual servers are managed
and as identical as
we can make them.
But also works up the stack
in terms of the software
that we're deploying
onto these things
and at the application level.
So concretely, what
does this mean?
Well, it breaks
down to two things.
So the first is
declarative management.
The idea here is that you
tell the system what you want.
And then you let the system
take care of that for you.
And when you deploy
and app to app engine,
that's exactly what
you're getting.
So that's an embodiment
of that technique.
This builds on top of this
idea of idempotency, which
means that if you do the same
thing over and over again,
you get the same result and
you're actually not moving
the system forward.
It's a key principle for being
able to deal with failures
because if something fails,
well you just try it again.
And then things will work.
Or you won't make the
system any worse, at least.
And then building
on top of this,
you have reproduceable
deployment.
So this is the idea that if
you're deploying an application
into your
infrastructure, you want
to make sure that you
can repeat that again,
and again, and again.
And this is important
because, it's not only
for your production
systems, but also when
you look your test dev
staging, however you
want to actually call your
pre-production systems,
you want to make sure that those
near your production systems
as closely as possible.
One of the hard won
lessons, if you've
done this stuff over time, is
that any issue, or any place,
where your production
infrastructure and your dev
and test infrastructure differ.
Eventually you're going
to find a bug there.
So the closer you can
make those things,
the more you can
protect yourself
from having issues make their
way out into production.
So moving from
Compute to Networking.
Google has made enormous
investments in networking.
And we've done it both
at the cluster level, how
one machine in one
data center talks
to another machine in that
data-- in that same data
center.
But also across the world.
In terms of wide
area networking,
how one machine on
one side of the world
talks to another machine on
the other side of the world.
Or how your phone or your
laptop talks to Google server.
And speaking specifically
about that wide area network,
we've done a lot of
really interesting work
about managing the
quality of service
across our worldwide network.
A little while ago,
[INAUDIBLE] presented a paper
at a conference
describing a system
called B4, that's B as in boy.
And it's a global
software defined WAN
and it's built on top of this
technology called OpenFlow,
that we've pioneered.
And we have the largest
implementation of it.
So we're really
pioneers in this way,
in terms of doing software
defined networking.
The last piece of
the networking puzzle
is high capacity load balancing.
And we look at this from,
how do you actually,
when something hits a data
center, how do you actually
disperse that traffic
to the right servers
in that particular data center?
To how do you actually make sure
that it gets to the right data
center?
If you have a lot of
them around the world.
And how do you actually
manage capacity
and actually overflow
from one place to another.
And a great example of
this is the 1 million
QPS test that we ran, and
wrote a blog post about,
I think it was mentioned
in the keynote.
So if you want to
learn more about that,
I highly recommend you read
that, you read that blog post.
So moving from
networking to storage.
At Google, pretty much
all of our storage
is done over the network.
And we built our networks to
be able to handle that load.
And this really
achieves two things.
So the first thing
that this achieves,
is it gives us the
opportunity to implement
reliable, durable systems.
Once you have that interface,
where you're actually
getting an API between you
and your storage system,
you have the opportunity to
build distributed, reliable,
durable systems there.
Great examples of this are
at the Block Storage level.
So our product,
Google Cloud Storage,
is built on top
of Colossus, which
is the successor for
GFS, which again, we
have another paper
out there for that
if you want to read
about how GFS works.
But having that distance
over the network
gives us the
opportunity to actually
be smart about replication,
about directing you
to the most performance replica.
And when you're doing a
read, things like that.
And we use that same technology,
both in our virtual VM Block
solution, to this is
persistent disk is part of GCE,
to Google Cloud Storage.
To our structured storage
and analytic systems,
including Google Cloud Data
Store, Google Cloud SQL,
and our analytics
systems, like BigQuery.
Back on that slide, so
one of the other things
I wanted to mention is
because of this networking,
we can actually integrate not
with just with Google systems,
but with other systems.
So there's also
another great blog post
detailing running Hadoop,
accessing Google Cloud Storage
directly, using
the Hadoop adapter
for Google Cloud Storage.
OK, so now, services and
glue, bringing all this stuff
together.
So the first thing I
want to talk about here
is common data formats
and API mechanisms.
And so with common data
formats, we use, pretty much
universally, internally, this
system called Protocol Buffers.
This is a way to
actually encode,
persist, and can read
that data in a way that's
tolerant to versioning
and changes,
and moving this stuff forward.
We use this, pretty much,
any time you write something
to disk, any time one
server connects to another,
we use Proto Buffs,
inside of Google.
Configuration files?
Proto Buffs.
You name it, Proto Buffs.
Now, there are-- we
have open sources,
so this is available
on code.google.com.
You can use this stuff
directly, if you want to.
But there's also a whole set
of similar systems out there
that give you a lot
of the same advantages
that you should check out.
And then we have API mechanisms.
How do you actually
expose services
so that one part of
your infrastructure
can talk to another
part of the structure?
And an interesting thing there
is that we built a set of API
middleware that
we use internally
to expose all of
our applications.
Things like the
GC-API, for example.
But we also make
this available to you
through this product called
Google Cloud Endpoints.
And so you can benefit from the
same rate limiting, and client
libraries, and all the
services that we've built.
That infrastructure
for our APIs,
you can leverage those
for your APIs, as well.
Monitoring and alerting.
If you don't monitor what's
going on with your application,
you don't know when
things are broken.
And Google has
enormous investments
around monitoring and alerting.
And we're working hard to
bring some of that to you.
I think you've seen
some of this today
with the integrative logging.
Another sort of
piece of this puzzle.
But there's a lot
more to come there.
Configuration brings back to
that declarative management.
But you really need to take a
holistic view of configuration.
Not only configuring which
resources you're running,
but also what's happening
inside of those resources.
And so a piece of
the puzzle here is,
things like we're going to
talk about later with manage
VMs and Deployment Manager.
But you can also leverage
open systems like Puppet Chef
or SaltStack to
manage what's going
on inside of a virtual machine.
And then finally, there's
automated build, testing,
and life cycle management.
This is making sure that you
know what you're building,
you know that it's
well tested, and you
know that it's actually
deployed when and how you
want it to be deployed.
There's a lot more
detail with that
in the session that
was co-scheduled
with this one, that's
going on in the other room.
So I recommend that
you check out the video
once it's posted on the
Cloud Platform Live site.
So bringing all
this stuff together,
I want to talk about
a couple of systems
that are uniquely Google.
And the first one is
Google Cloud Data Store.
So this is, started life as the
Google App Engine Data Store,
but now it's available as
a separate RESTful API,
so that you can access
it outside of the context
of an App Engine app.
This is built on top of
a couple of technologies
that, again, we've
released papers about,
including Megastore in BigTable.
These are really
interesting papers
that I recommend
you take a look at.
But one of, the most
interesting things
here is that these
things take advantage
of Google's entire data center.
So when you buy some space in
Google's Cloud Data Center,
you're just putting items there.
And you let us take
care of the scale.
And you're not buying a
discrete set of resources.
Instead, you're
actually buying more
of a horizontal slice of
the entire Data Center.
Which means that as you scale
from the small to the very big,
if you structure your
schema correctly,
you're not going to hit
any cliffs along the way.
And you won't have to make
discrete decisions that, oh I'm
going to buy another
chunk of capacity.
And so this really is
bringing the elasticity
that is promised in
the Cloud to life.
Another similar system
here is BigQuery.
There was a session earlier
that went into a lot more detail
here.
But I just want to
put some numbers, sort
of some hypothetical numbers,
and actually drive home
this point of actually using the
entire sort of horizontal slice
of the Data Center.
And oh, and by the way, there's
a paper on BigQuery also
the Dramel.
This is a screenshot of
one of the pages there.
So let's say that internally,
hypothetically, Dremel
uses-- or BigQuery uses, 1,200
spindles to actually execute
your query-- 1,200
spinning disks.
I actually don't know
how many there are, so
don't quote me on that.
So hypothetically, let's say
that it takes half a second
to actually running a query.
You're essentially buying
half a second of spindle time
across 1,200 spindles.
That's the same as buying a
single spindle for 10 minutes.
As far as Google is concerned,
that's the same cost.
When you have enough customers
actually accessing that,
it's actually the same
amount to spindle time.
It's just unevenly distributed.
But it's a game
changer when you're
looking at the service in terms
of getting wall time results.
Running a query that
takes 10 minutes
is not very interesting.
Running a query that
takes half a second
is very, very interesting.
So hopefully this
gives you a taste
of what it's like to be an
engineer at Google, what
our internal
platform looks like.
And a little bit of a
hint of some of the stuff
that you're going to be seeing
over the next coming months.
So back to you, nothing Navneet.
[APPLAUSE]
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thanks, Joe.
So if you've been watching
us over the past few months,
you've seen several
of these pieces
in action on the Cloud platform.
We've talked about, for
example, how our internal Dramel
system is BigQuery,
that you have access to.
But I wanted to just spend
a few minutes recapping
some of the more interesting
highlights of the capabilities
we've launched recently.
So Compute Engine
went GA in December.
And we've launched
several enhancements.
How many of you were
here at the keynote?
So OK, a good number of you.
So if you were there,
and if you want,
I encourage you to
watch the video later.
We did a demonstration
of this technology, which
we call Transparent Maintenance.
Let me go into a bit more
background about Transparent
Maintenance.
So it turns out
that the best way
to keep any system functioning,
frankly, not just computing
systems, is preventive
maintenance.
You want to make sure all
the components of the system
are functioning as
well as possible.
Transferring that over
into the computer plate,
you want to make sure that, for
example, your data center power
infrastructure works well.
You want to make sure
that your hardware is
maintained properly.
You want to make sure that your
software, your host software,
is patched whenever there
is a security update.
You want to make sure
everything is running, frankly,
as smoothly as
possible, so you get
the most reliable, most secure
environment for all of it,
for everyone.
Now, it turns out that many of
these things I talked about,
like patching host software,
or doing power maintenance,
are actually disruptive events.
Right?
If you have something
running on a machine,
and you need to
upgrade the host OS,
it's going to affect the VM.
If you want to do
power maintenance
and make sure generators
work by flipping the switch,
it's going to effectively end.
So you could have
a choice, I mean,
that's one way to go about it.
You could have a choice between
delaying those maintenances
and hoping that
things don't go wrong.
And so having fewer
disruptions to running VMs.
Or, you could potentially go
the other way, and just say,
we're going to do
preventive maintenance.
Which means, you will
have planned downtime,
and that's just how things work.
We actually didn't want to
go either of those routes.
We wanted to effectively let you
have your cake and eat it too.
We wanted to give you a
minimal number of disruption
on your VMs, while
simultaneously keeping
our infrastructure as
secure, and as efficient,
and as reliably
running as possible.
And so we launched
this technology
called Transparent Maintenance.
Which really was us going
back to the drawing board
and saying, how do you actually
design datacenter operations
from the ground up so that
the applications running there
can survive a maintenance event.
So what we're doing,
really, and just
to peel back the
covers a bit, is
we're actually
taking running VMs
and moving them out of the
way of a maintenance event.
So if we know a particular
rack is about to be maintained,
we'll take all the VMs on that
rack, move them somewhere else,
perform the maintenance
of the rack,
and now, you have
an updated rack.
And we do this very quickly
throughout the whole data
center, which means,
that actually, we
can keep our software and
hardware running really
efficiently without
impacting you.
So there's a--
like I said, there
was a great demo in the keynote
if you didn't catch that,
I really encourage
you watching that.
Because it really drives the
point home about how little
the impact to VM is when
we're doing this stuff.
OK, let me talk about
pricing a bit more.
Now, we already spent a lot of
time about this in the keynote,
so I don't want to reiterate
the points he talked about.
I do want to share
some more color.
So let me talk about
virtual machine pricing.
So one of the things, which
is basically a truism,
is that, when you run
a sustained workload,
it costs less, whether you're
doing that on your own hardware
or you're doing it
in the Cloud, right?
It costs the provider
less because provisioning
for spikes costs money,
If this hardware,
which has not been used
for a large amount of time.
And some of that
evens out when you're
talking about Cloud Scale
because different customers
spike at different times.
But it's still
fundamentally a problem.
And so you want to make
sure that customers
who are doing
sustained workloads
are actually getting
the best possible price.
Now, one of the traditional ways
that many Cloud providers have
looked to solve this
is through commitments.
So they kind of know, because
you've committed to them what
you're going to be
doing on that platform,
and they kind of
structure pricing
in a way to incentivizes,
kind of, sustained use.
And that's a perfectly fine
way to solve the problem.
But it creates a
few other problems
that we wanted to avoid.
Specifically, it forces you
to make a commitment, right?
You have to choose the kind of
machine you're going to run,
and probably commit to
it for a year or three.
And so if you decide
that suddenly,
actually, I kind of
think this is OK,
but I want a bit
more RAM on this.
And I want to do something else.
Well, you've already
committed to the other thing.
And now, you can't get the
best price on that other thing.
And so we wanted to
make sure that you
could get the best
possible price
without any upfront
payments, without having
to wade through a
large menu of options.
Just get the best price
for your workload.
And so what we did was, we
introduced sustained use
pricing.
And what, and we talk
about how that works.
So I'm going to use a real
world example for that.
So let's say, and this is
a very small application,
but you have 1 VM running
your application today.
You start at the
beginning of April.
You run that VM for about
10 days, during which you're
doing some analysis using
BigQuery on your logs,
and you find out, there is
probably some optimization
you could do to make sure
your pages load faster.
Right?
So you do that on a second VM.
You send some
traffic to that VM,
sort of canary it, and make
sure that you haven't actually
changed anything for the
worse, everything works well.
After about four or
five days of testing,
you find that
actually, yes, you have
founded a meaningful
optimization.
This is how you want to
run your application.
You shut down the first VM,
you keep the second VM running.
Your users love this,
five days later you
have tons more traffic, and
you need to set up a second VM
to serve all that
additional traffic.
And you keep that second
VM running the whole month.
So that's kind of
what this looks
like, the three VMs
running through the month.
So how does that look like
from a sustained use discount
perspective?
How do we actually treat
that in terms of the prices
we offer you?
Well, so what we
basically do is we kind of
play a little game of
Tetris here, right?
We look at how you used
VMs during the month.
So if you look at the
chart on the screen,
for the first 10 days
you had one VM running.
The second five days,
five day after that
you had two VMs running.
Then you had a short
period when you had just
the new updated VM
running for five days.
And then for the
rest of the month
you've got two VMs running,
serving all your traffic.
So that's basically what we do.
We say, you know, as
far as we're concerned,
this is two logical VMs.
You had one logical VM
running the entire month.
And so you used it
for 100% and you
get a 30% discount on that VM.
You had a second VM which
ran, although disjointedly,
for about a half the month.
And so you get a
discount on that too.
You get a 10% discount on that.
And so we are
automatically taking
care of all the complexities
so that you build and operate
your service in a way
that makes sense to you.
So you don't have to
do anything artificial
to make sure you
get the best price.
We take care of that for you.
And that's really
what we believe
is at the heart of Cloud, right?
The provider should
handle the complexities
so you get a simple experience,
so that's what we're all about.
OK.
So let's talk about disk.
Joe talked a bit
about how at Google we
build all of our storage
over the network, right?
So we believe that
there's tons of benefits
to that, for example,
you can scale a computer
and storage independently.
You shouldn't have to buy a
really beefy compute machine
to get a lot of storage.
You shouldn't necessarily
buy a ton of storage
and not be able to use
it because you want
to beefy compute machine,
you should use what you need.
At the same time, you get
benefits like Network Attach
Storage lets you do things
like Snapshot your storage.
So you can go back to a
previous point in time
if something breaks.
Or you can you know,
basically look at tuning,
how move your storage
from one VM to another.
So let's say, you
have a SQL database
that's running a
two core machine,
you want to run a
four core machine.
Shut down the two core
machine, spit up the same disk
as on the four core machine.
You're good to go, right?
So it makes your
operation a lot simpler.
It makes everything
more reliable,
more easy to run and administer.
And so we wanted to
make sure that you
got all those benefits,
but at a good price.
And so what we did
was we actually
launched the system disk, which
is our network attached disk,
at the same price
as a scratch disk.
So basically, you get all
the benefits of network disk
with a single per
gigabyte price that
includes all the I/O,
which scales its size.
So if you want to
scale your performance,
you just know how to do
it, you just scale size.
It's very predictable,
you don't have
any two independent
dimensions to think about.
And it's very cheap.
And so that's really,
you know, again,
going back to the
heart of offering you
a simple, powerful mechanism
to build your applications.
That's what we're about.
OK, so let's talk
App Engine briefly.
We've done a lot on
App Engine pricing,
and really, to get
the full flavor for it
you should just visit the site.
But I wanted to highlight
some of the changes we've
made there.
We've drastically simplified
pricing across the board.
We've cut the price for
instance hours by 37.5%.
Dedicated Memcache by 50%.
And for Datastore Writes,
which was one of our most
frequently received
requests, by 33%.
We've also taken a number of
services that were previously
charged for
independently, and we've
bundled them into
the price App Engine.
And so overall, you see a much
simpler, much shorter price
sheet with lower prices
across the board.
OK.
So let's talk about
networking here.
We've launched several advances
in the area of networking,
starting with low level
things, like giving you
access to the software
defined router that underlies
the network through
our capabilities
in advanced routing.
We also launched higher level
capabilities like, layer 3 load
balancing, and
protocol forwarding.
And today, we are also
announcing a new service,
Google Cloud DNS,
which gives you
access to same
DNS infrastructure
that we use to serve all
of our own DNS queries,
to serve your own domains.
And so you get access to the
same low latency worldwide
serving, you have Command
Line API Access to it,
and it's priced at a
very simple low price.
OK, moving on, let's talk
about operating systems.
We've worked with commercial
software providers like Red Hat
and SuSE to provide
their operating
systems on computer engine.
We also work with the community
to provide that [INAUDIBLE]
and recently, FreeBSD, which was
our first non-Linux OS to you.
Now, we didn't
stop there though.
We actually made the underlying
virtualization technology
available to you.
So that if you wanted to use
a different distribution,
you can bring your own
distribution to Compute Engine.
And today we're announcing
the limited preview
of Windows supported
Compute Engine.
So if you are one
of those developers
who has a portion of
your, or frankly, all,
of your infrastructure
running on Windows,
you can now get that on
Compute Engine, as well.
So App Engine, we haven't taken
our off the gas there either.
So let's talk about some
of the changes we've made.
We recently launched the
Modules capability App Engine,
which lets you take
your App Engine app
and build it in terms of a
number of different modules,
components.
And you can have each of these
components scale independently.
You can have them
perform differently,
have different performance
characteristics.
You can even use different
programming languages.
So let's say, you're in
a company where you have,
you know, the people
who built the back end
parts of the application
really like coding
in Java and the people
who build the front end
are all about Python.
They can do that.
You can build the two
different modules independently
and have them talk
to each other.
So you can actually
really get the benefits
of componentization
and modulization
for your application.
Since we launched the php,
which is a fourth officially
supported language
on App Engine,
we've seen great traction.
For example, Sony Music
used php on App Engine
to serve back end for
One Direction Day, which
was actually, the largest
streaming event on YouTube.
Memcache is something
a lot of developers
use to build scalability
and performance
and acceleration for
the applications.
And one of the things App
Engine has offered for while
is access to a
shared Memcache pool
where you can actually
get all those benefits
without having to do
any advanced planning.
So you just show up
and use memcache API
and you have Memcache.
But it turns out that for
some specific applications,
you actually benefit
from the ability
to do some of that planning and
get a dedicated pool so you can
control the
performance parameters
for your application.
And so for those developers,
we launched Dedicated Memcache,
which as of today, is now
$0.6 per gigabyte, per hour.
And we've seen great
traction there too.
We now have over 10 terabytes
of dedicated Memcache
being served to our developers.
Now again, we showed you a demo
of this in the keynote today,
Git Push to Deploy, but
I wanted to kind of talk
about the philosophy behind it.
So really, we believe
that using tools
that you're familiar with, and
being able to integrate those
tightly with the
platform, gives you
much, much faster
innovation cycles.
It makes it much easier
to build the applications
on the platform.
And so Git Push to Deploy
capability effectively
lets you connect
any Git repository
to App Engine application.
And have a Git Push
to come and deploy.
And so you can iterate much
faster on App Engine using it
Git Push to Deploy.
OK, so today when
you come and try
to build and application
in the Cloud,
you're often faced
with a choice.
Do you want to build the
application on infrastructure
as a service, and get all the
benefits of a very flexible
platform, but have to do a
lot of the plumbing yourself,
right?
You have to build a bunch of
management pieces yourself.
Or, you could choose to build
on a platform as a service,
and get a lot of
agility because you
don't have to build
all that plumbing.
You don't have to tweak
it, fine tune it, learn
how to make it work
better for yourself,
you just focus on your own code.
But to do that, you have
to fit within a framework
that the platform
provider defines.
So that they can do all that
managment for you, right?
That turns out that we
think that this is actually
a flase dichotomy.
It shouldn't have
to be a trade off.
If what you want to be able
to do is focus on your code
and not worry about
the mundane details
that it takes to maintain
and run your application,
you can do that
with a combination
of several new technologies
we're launching today.
Specifically, we think
that these technologies are
the foundation of the next
Generation Cloud, where
you get all the productivity,
all the art of management
of platform as a
service, but you get that
with the open and
flexible environment
that [INAUDIBLE] provide.
So to talk about some new
technology in that area,
manage virtual machines,
deployment manager, and replica
pools, I'd like to
invite Chris Ramsdale.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Thanks, Navneet.
As Navneet mentioned,
I'm a Product Manager
for the Google Cloud Platform.
I was up for the keynote
demoing Manage VMs today.
And so what I'm
going to talk about
is that technology plus
two others that we believe
will, not only end this
false dichotomy where
you have to select as a
customer, as a developer,
between platform as a service
or infrastructure as a service,
but also how we're going to
enhance developer productivity
when building Cloud
based applications.
So first of all, how many
App Engine developers
do we have in the
crowd right now?
OK, all right.
How many of you are actually
building on virtual machines,
as well, be it Amazon,
or [INAUDIBLE] or GC?
OK, I'm going to
get a good blend.
This great, this is great.
OK so let me jump right in.
One of the first
technologies that we
had alluded to in the
keynote today is Manage VMs.
With Manage VMs, you get
the control and the power
and flexibility of
Compute Engine VMs
mixed with, and combined with,
the proven auto management
capabilities of App Engine.
For example, say you're
an App Engine developer,
you're building an application.
Then suddenly, you
want to have access
to a language or a library,
or some native resource,
that you don't have access to.
That a typical platform
as a service offering
doesn't support.
Now, typically what happens,
is you're pushed off a cliff
into the infrastructure
as a service world.
And you're left managing
all by yourself,
in managing the
entire deployment.
With Manage VMs
that's not the case.
We can handle that
management for you.
Alternatively, say you
start with a vanilla
VM, an unmanaged Compute
Engine VM, for example.
And you build out your
solution and it's running,
and at some point in time
you want us to manage it.
You can flip that unmanaged
VM to being a managed
VM and Google Cloud
Platform takes over for you.
And for more on that,
I encourage you,
there's a session at 2:30 called
Runtime Yours, that our friend
Andrew Jessup is giving with
the help of a few others
you should definitely check out.
But it's not just about
the openness there.
It's not just about access
to the native resources
or being able to
run native code.
There's much more
to it, as well.
With Manage VMs you
get Google SREs,
you get a team of Sight
Reliable Engineers that
are monitoring deployments,
co-locating them, and making
sure everything's
running smoothly.
Manage VMs has access to
all of our managed services.
So Datastore, Task
Queues and Memcache.
And furthermore, it's not
just about communication
between your compute and
our managed services.
It's about communication
between all
of the compute units
inside your application,
inside your project.
For example, say you're
running a bit of your front
ends in App Engine today.
Maybe it's built
in Python, maybe
it's built in PHP, who
knows, pick your runtime.
But you've also got
some back end processing
that's running on Manage VMs.
Because we're
managing those VMs,
our services and our
SRE team can make sure
that everything is
co-located so you
get low latency and improved
overall performance.
And finally, it's about
developer productivity.
And because of that, we've
brought all this technology
and Manage VMs through our
Cloud SDK so you can get
added via the command
line or developer consule
as I showed today.
The second technology
is Replica Pools.
Replica Pools are in addition
to our core compute API.
As Joe had mentioned earlier on,
one of the interesting problems
that we had to
solve at Google, was
how do you have declarative
management and reproduceable
deployments.
How do you build a
system that optimizes
so that you don't have
special snowflakes?
Turns out that Manage VMs
we did that as well, right?
When we looked at
it and said, how
can we take what we've
learned at Google,
and bring that through
to external developers
so that our customers could
use it in the same way we have?
Replica Pools is just that.
A consistent, easy
to use mechanism
for getting homogeneous, fleet
of VMs running in production.
All you have to do
as a developer is
specify a template.
That template
specifies a base image.
A set of commands that
should be run in start up.
Netowrk configuration, and the
initial number of instances
that you want up and running.
And with Replica Pools, much
like the rest of Google Cloud
Platform, what
we're trying to do
is take on some
of the complexity.
And sometimes the
mundane task is
running Cloud based
application, so that you
can focus on applications, and
awesome end user experiences.
And finally, because developer
productivity is near and dear
to our heart, we're bringing
all this great technology
through to our SDK via a new
component called Deployment
Manager.
With Deployment Manager,
you can take and specify
end number of VMs to be
managed as a single unit.
And with that single unit
you can apply a health model.
So our system can then
take and do health
checking against
that health model
and healing when there's
an issue that arises.
We also can specify an
auto-scaling policy so
that our system can go and
stamp out new VMs as traffic
increases, or as utilization
across CPU or memory
increases as well.
So we not only think
that it's an actual,
not only do we think that
Development Manager--
or Deployment Manager, excuse
me-- is a way for developers
to interact with
complex environments.
We also think it's
a very great way
to get started with some
of these new capabilities
or reducing to our platform.
So those are the
three new technologies
that we're announcing today
and talking about in terms
of building Cloud
based applications.
What I want to do is I
want to take a step back,
and I want to look at
how we're transitioning
from a binary decision
where you have
to choose upfront how
much management you want,
platform of service or
infrastructure as a service,
and change that into a
spectrum of management options
that you can choose from as
your application evolves.
OK.
So we take a look at the stack
with this new technology,
we see that we actually have a
collection of tiered services
that layer on top of each other.
At the lowest level, you've
got the best of breed VMs
with compute engine
VMs where you're
managing the rest of the stack.
Maybe it's you, maybe you are
using open source technologies
like Chef, Puppet, or
SaltStack, but you're
managing that portion.
Or you decide that
you want, you know
what, I want Google to
manage my deployments.
So via Replica Pools.
So we're managing
the deployments
and you're managing things
like the OS updates, security
patches, and maybe
you're deploying
some kind of centralized
logging and monitoring.
But let's say you want
out of that business
as well, moving up the stack.
You can have Google Manager VMs.
At this point in
time, we're managing
everything underneath that.
And what you're
really focusing on
is managing the software
that's running inside of there.
So maybe it's your serving
stack, maybe it's engine x,
whatever you may want.
But then for some
workloads, you really
just want to focus on the
application and the end user
experience and you want to
let Google manage pretty
much the entire stack below you.
And it's at this
level you're really
taking advantage of the benefits
of platform as a service.
You get auto updated
software, integrated APIs,
and smart defaults.
Right?
But because these are
running on managed VMs,
you're not losing that
control and that power
of the underlying
infrastructure.
You can always get at the native
network, native network stack,
or the file system,
or run native code.
So what we do is, and,
looking at this holistically,
we believe that
we're shifting away
from having developers
have to choose upfront
how much management they want.
And as their
application evolves,
they can switch the
amount of management
that they have, moving
between these various tiers,
so that evolves with
your application,
without you having to do a huge
code rewrite or refactoring.
So that's a bunch of me
talking, a bunch of slides,
so to see this in
action, I'm going
to bring up one of our amazing
Developer Advocates, Brian
Dorsey.
BRIAN DORSEY: Thank you, sir.
Hello everybody.
It's almost demo time.
OK, so after all of
these really big ideas,
we need a really
big demo, right?
So sudoku, how do you
get bigger than that?
It's this international,
world sensation.
It's big in Japan.
If you haven't seen
sudoku, it's actually
a fill in the blank puzzle game.
Got numbers, just don't repeat
them horizontally, vertically,
or in the same square, right?
So let's use Google Cloud
to play some Sudoku.
So first off, we need
to teach the computer
to actually solve Sudoku.
And we're lucky there because
Peter Norvig, the gentleman who
actually wrote the book on
AI, wrote this fantastic essay
that I highly recommend
you take a look at.
And it walks through
all the permutations
of how to write a Sudoku solver
in Python, including code,
so we've got that, awesome.
But what I'd like
to do, is actually
solve like, real
physical puzzles, right?
Like I want to take this
puzzle and solve it.
So we've got to get this
into the computer somehow.
And that means computer vision.
So we're lucky there as well.
There's a fantastic
library called OpenCV,
that is a collection of computer
vision algorithms written in C
and C++.
So I should be
good to go, right?
I'll just mash those
together and I'm done.
And this hits that
like, classic dilemma,
that we've talked about like
in the keynote and stage here,
and as a developer, I
run into it all the time.
I want it to be really
easy to get my stuff out.
I want it to be really reliable,
automatically maintained.
But at some point, you run into
a wall with whatever system
you're using.
And in this case, the wall
is that I need this C and C++
library.
So even if I had the whole
thing written on App Engine,
I still have a place to run
this computer vision code.
And so I can run that
on Compute Engine.
It's going to run great.
But then I've kind
of signed back up
for all of the maintenance
and automation.
So that's why I'm just super
excited about Managed VMs.
So here's what this looks like,
the Sudoku solver in the cloud.
We've got App Engine,
it's a web app.
So App Engine is handling all
of the regular apps serving
HTTP and that sort of thing.
We've got a special
URL that accepts
an image as a foreign post.
And that ends up going
back into task queues,
and then we run the
actual computer vision
on Compute Engine.
So awesome.
From the developer prospective,
what that looks like is,
the front end part is
regular App Engine.
So we've got an app.yaml
here, standard, normal thing.
On this side, we have what
managed VMs looks like.
And there's very few changes.
We're using modules,
the same bit that
lets you use different
programming languages
or different performance
characteristics.
And this extra line,
VM equals true,
which tells the
infrastructure, by the way,
deploy this code to
VMs and run it for me.
And there's another
file that lets
you say what URLs
go to which module.
So then this is the actual
script where my code is.
And down at the bottom is the
key and most important part.
But that's where
we specify which
Compute Engine machines we use.
So we can choose any kind
of Compute Engine instance,
you know, 1, 2,
4, 8 CPUs or more.
You can say I need a
high CPU, or high memory,
to do this workload.
And at the bottom, you
can actually just say,
list your dependencies as
app to get install line.
So in this case, I want to have
the Python bindings for open CV
and everything it needs.
And I just put one line there
and Python open CV and it
brings in like the 30+ shared
libraries and everything it
needs.
So OK.
And then its deployment time.
So you've got one command,
and deploys your whole app
to a given version.
You've got all the
App Engine goodness
where you can say OK, this
version is good enough.
Let's make that
the production one.
And let's go to the slides.
Or I'm sorry, let's
go to the demo.
OK.
So on demo, and
here we we've got
a Web App it's a real Web App.
This is our Sudoku Solver.
I've got a webcam hooked up.
Hello everyone.
And right here, if we pull
the cord out of the way,
we will try to get
an actual image
that we're going
to try to solve.
So we've got this image.
And it's saved there.
And when I hit Solve
here, it's going
to send that off the App Engine.
It goes through
this architecture
we talked about, hits the task
queue, hits Compute Engine,
saves it in Cloud
Storage, and goes online.
So moment of truth, we hit
the button, send it on out,
and solved.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is a probably
my life solved forever.
I never have to solve
another Sudoku puzzle.
We're good.
So that's pretty cool.
But I just wanted to
kind of poke around
behind the scenes a
little bit and show you
what this looks like.
So this is our
developer's console.
And we're down in the
Compute Engine section here.
And so we can
actually see, we have
a couple of running instances.
And that's this demo
actually running.
We can take a look in
a particular instance,
see different things
about it, get its name,
that we're going to
need here in a moment.
And let's dive to
the command line.
And we're still
connected, awesome.
So they talked
earlier about how--
so these are manage VMs, right?
The Google infrastructure
runs these VMs for you,
so you don't really want
them to be different.
We don't want snowflakes here.
So but sometimes, you want to
go take a look under the covers,
and see what things
actually look like.
So there's a command for that.
glcloud computer debug.
And then give it the
current directory
that you're working in.
And it will go out and
say, OK, these guys
are ready for debugging.
And we can SSH into this
instance that we got there.
Connects off and, just to
prove it, look at that.
We're in this instance.
And it's ready to go.
So now, being a
developer, right?
I like to have environments
look a certain way.
So I might go apt-get
install tmux, or maybe vim.
Go ahead and kind of get
things in there a little bit.
It's also a real virtual
machine with all,
and a Google Cloud
computer-- Compute Engine
virtual machine, with all
of our security set up,
the way it works-- easy for you.
So I can use gsutil
and pull a file down
from Cloud Storage that contains
my tmux config, because I
like things this way.
And I have to type
the command correctly.
Software.
And I bring that
down, run tmux, I'm
all in, ready to do some
looking around this machine.
So let's first off, we'll
go into var/log/app.engine
and look around there.
We can use vim, go and take
a look at the request log.
See a bunch of help
checks coming through.
That looks pretty OK.
Maybe we want to see
how the network like.
So what's going
on in the network?
So sudo apt-get install.
And we'll look at
iftop, for example.
Bring that down.
Kind of run, we need
to be root to do that.
Run iftop, kind
of see how things
are going in the backend.
You can see a little
bit of activity there,
but nothing unusual.
I keep debugging,
[INAUDIBLE], and we'll just
assume that I look
through here and notice
it's really my code, as it
usually is, eating all the CPU.
So I'm going to go back
and like, fix my code.
And that pretty
much wraps it up.
Wait, you just
created a snowflake.
You installed a bunch
of stuff on a machine,
and like, that might
break something.
Oh, I did.
I think this will be OK,
I didn't do that much.
Like--
That's how this happens.
That's how you get
yourself into trouble
OK, point taken.
I've made that mistake before.
So how do we fix this?
Basically, here's this
instance we have, again.
And so I can go
down to the bottom
and just click Delete
amd really delete this.
And trust that the Manage VMs
infrastructure will start up
new ones to run the right
number of instances.
So it's all good to go.
So back to the slides.
And so here is what
that looked like.
So we take things in.
App Engine handles all
of the main web requests.
So this is regular App Engine
auto-scaling, scaling up
to all the things
you've seen before.
We create a buffer in task
queues, so that you know,
if we get a sudden load spike
and then it goes right back
down, we can kind of, have
a few more things there.
And then we're using
application specific scaling
on the Sudoku solvers
side of things.
And what that looks like
in code, it's really easy.
I basically just make
a one call and say,
I want this many
instances running.
So what I can do is I can watch
the stats on that task queue,
for example, and say
oh, it's gotten behind,
let's start some more instances.
Or it's all caught up, we
can shut some more down.
So there we go.
Thank you very much
[APPLAUSE]
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thanks, Brian.
So let me just
quickly wrap this up.
What did we learn today?
So Joe talked about how we
build applications at Google.
[COUGH]
Pardon me.
He talked about a
number of the patterns
that we found to
work really well.
Like, for example, storing
your data on the network.
Like making sure you avoid
snowflakes, thanks Brian
and Joe.
Making sure that fundamentally,
that you try to leverage
as much as possible
the learning of people
that came before you
by leveraging platforms
that embody what
they've learned.
And you know, we'll
continue to share details
about that software, we
will continue to do so.
We also talked
about how we believe
that the choice
between infrastructure
as a service and flexibility.
And pass, and sort of
time to market and develop
a productivity is
actually a false choice.
And we're going to keep
making that something
that you don't have to worry
about in the days to come.
We talked about several products
that make this vision of ours
a reality.
Manage VMs, we talked
about Deployment Manager.
And Replica Pools that are
different levels of abstraction
and different levels
of detail that you
employ some of the patterns
that Joe talked about.
And then I just
want to leave you
with one thought, which is that
we're just getting started.
What you've seen today
is just the beginning.
There's lots more to come
from us in the days and months
to come.
We'd love to have you
come and sign up and try
Manage VMs, the URL for
that is on the screen.
And we've also pulled
together some resources that
go into more detail about the
subjects that Joe talked about,
as well as some of the products
that we announced today,
that URL is on the
screen right now.
Thank you very much.
And we've love to take
any questions you have.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So you've
talked a lot about VMs,
nobody has said a
word about containers.
Do you envision making
containerization
a mode which could be available
on the Cloud infrastructure.
JOE BEDA: We've been
looking really closely
at all the technology
that's been
developing around containers.
And in fact, Google
actually submitted a bunch
of that technology
upstream in terms
of sea groups,
that was originally
something that was
built inside of Google.
And we think it's
a perfect fit for
those repeatable deployments.
And so I think it's still early.
People are still
getting used to that.
I mean, we've been doing that
type of stuff inside of Google
all the time.
But it's super complementary.
And so yeah.
I think it's a great technique,
and using those in conjunction
with the stuff that we're doing
here is a great way to go.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: And I
had mentioned this this
when I was speaking that there
is a session called Runtime
Yours, that's scheduled
at 2:30, where
we talk a little bit about
some of these technologies
we are looking at, and how they
might work with our platform.
So I encourage you, if
interested, to go check it out.
BRIAN DORSEY: Others?
AUDIENCE:You listed several
different levels of management
for VMs.
Is the pricing per hour
the same on all those?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yes it is.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOE BEDA: There's a couple
questions up front here.
You up here.
Thanks for waiting
for the mic, guys.
Make it easier for everybody
who's listening remotely.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
story for get to deploy
for Compute Engine
and or Managed VMs?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yes,
so that's something
that we're working on.
So what you've seen
today was git push deploy
going to app engine.
But clearly, the
next path we're going
to go down, since a
lot of this is running
through the same deployment
architecture, this
is the whole idea of
convergence, right?
When we converge and it actually
works for any compute unit
that we have at Google.
So the next steps
on the roadmap is
to work with unmanaged Compute
Engine VMs and managed VMs
that we were
talking about today.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just
a quick question
about the endpoints,
the RESTful API.
Is that only at the
App Engine level?
Or does the VM also include,
that was a little bit unclear.
JOE BEDA:Well currently,
Cloud Endpoint is something
that's only available
through App Engine,
through the App Engine,
sort of, front door.
But that's the type
of thing that we'd
be looking at expanding.
Nothing ready to announce.
BRIAN DORSEY: But you can
use the same technique
that we did the Sudoku solver
to have the endpoints cooperate
with workloads that are
also running on Managed VMs.
AUDIENCE: But then you're
stuck with the languages
that you have.
BRIAN DORSEY: For that
actual part, right.
NAVNEET JONEJA: For
the front end, correct.
Yes.
JOE BEDA: Any, may be
blocked by a pillar,
there we go, a
couple over there.
NAVNEET JONEJA: We
have, over here.
In the blue.
AUDIENCE: Just a clarification
on that question, they said,
so when you do on VMs, any
changes, like packages,
installs, and things like that.
Is the-- how do you
manage that today?
Do you have, like let's say if
you did something on the VMs
and you now have
to deploy new VM,
how do you save it back
and then laucnh a new VM.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Right.
So it's a really question.
So the typical life cycle
that we're encouraging here
is, that you start with
Declarative Management,
that I've shown a
couple of times,
the Brian showed as well.
To say, this is what I
want running on these VMs.
And assuming there's no
problems, that's great.
We're looking into ways
that we can turn that
into a static binary that we can
easily scale up and scale down
and things like that.
In the case that you do want
to debug those VMs and SSH
and do something like
Brian did where you've got,
you know, various open source
technologies running on there.
We expect that you'll
either, for example,
if you're debugging, you
figure out what's going on
and you make that
change locally.
And, or doing, or in your
git repository, for example.
And then once that's
done, you do a push.
And because these
Managed VMs are funneling
through the same
deployment architecture
that App Engine
has, you get things
like, versioning out the
box, rolling deployments,
the ability to canary traffic,
shift it, do a slow roll out,
things like that.
But the idea is that you
go into those machines,
you figure out
what's going on, you
figure there's a problem
with one of them.
And say, one of a fleet of say,
10 or 20, whatever it may be.
And say OK, I've got
it, this is probably
systemic across my entire fleet.
I'm going to change it locally,
store wherever you need to,
do a push that
revs your version,
test it out, do a
slow deployment over,
and you're good to go.
And then you can get rid of
the minus one of the VMs.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So let
me just, can I just
take a step back and talk
about that conceptually?
I mean, the goal here, with both
Deployment Manager and Manage
VMs is to make it very easy
to build the patterns that
will scale with you
and that would lead you
to a place where you have a
well running application, right?
So you want to specify
everything declaratively,
so that when you spit out more
VMs, when the system spits
up more VMs, they look
like all the others.
There's no weird cases where
one VM is faster than the rest,
you don't know
why or vice versa.
Right?
So the two are
designed to do that.
But in the Manage VMs demo,
I know if you caught this,
but I'll just kind of
just reiterate this again.
The stuff that Brian
installed with app
get, he could have
also specified
in the app.yamel file, right?
So once you figure out,
let's say you-- there's
a version of OpenSSH that you
want to install on the VM.
And the version you
have is not working.
You debug, you find
a version that works.
You just go back, update
your app.yamel file, right?
And you say, I want
to use this version.
The next time around, you
have the right version
on all your VMs.
So if you manage it
declaratively rather than
configuring on the fly, you
have a much better running
application.
And that's kind
of the goal here.
Does that help?
Thanks.
AUDIENCE:I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about
dependency version management.
Like, if the Python
open CV library
were to have a new
version, it seems
like you'd be creating
snowflakes if one of them
gets rebooted and
gets the new version
of the library
versus the other VMs.
And maybe it breaks some
dependency tree that you have
that some library
call that you may
and so only that
instance is broken.
I'm wondering if you can
talk about that a little bit.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So
in that case though,
the-- you would
actually be installing
the version of OpenCV.
So you would say, I
want to have OpenCV
and you can pass in,
I want to have OpenCV,
3.1, or 3.2, or 3.3.
AUDIENCE: So you can pass in
a version number and pin it?
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Right.
But then there's actually
another good point.
Actually, I don't know
if you meant this,
but I'm going to kind of
tease it out of there.
That again, because you're
running on the deployment
infrastructure that we
have, you can do things
like versioning very easily.
You say, you know what, I want
to test out version 3.2 or 3
dot x of OpenCV.
I do that with a new version,
that's not my default version.
So all my live traffic
here is running
back to what I know was good.
I want to canary a new one.
I'll do some QA, do some
integration testing,
things look good.
Flip the bit, and now you've
got all the traffic running
to the new updated
OpenCV insert,
open source technology there.
JOE BEDA: Yeah,
and I just wanted
one more fine point on that.
I mean, this is when
leveraging something
like the container technology
that was mentioned earlier
can really come into play.
Because now, you have
essentially an artifact,
which is that container image,
that really encapsulates
everything about
your application
that you're interested in.
And so those things work
really well together
in terms of trying to actually
specify all the versions down
to the umpteenth degree that
you're actually working with.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: You got a
question in the back there?
While he's making
his way back I want
to highlight another
fine point there, too.
That while you can
specify the technology
you want to run on
these Managed VMs,
you can also take advantage of
App Engine's manage runtimes.
So Java, Python, PHP, et cetera.
And in that case, we actually
will do the updating for you,
right?
So if we realize that there is
a security patch that we need
to update for that runtime,
we can do it for you.
Just like we've
done in the past.
So I don't know if
everybody knows,
but if you're a Java
developer on App Engine,
back over this last summer
we did an update from Java 6
to Java 7.
On the behalf of
developers, we upgraded
millions of applications
in C2, like in real time.
And we did that because we
could actually do a clone of it,
do some canary.
Run some tests, run some
anonymized traffic back
at those things to make
sure everything was working
and that we felt comfortable.
Roll that deployment
out and we're
going to make that available
as well, within managed VMs.
AUDIENCE: So this
is a quick follow up
to the question about
version packages.
What's the default behavior if
you don't specify a version?
Are they upgraded and
are some machines--
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So we don't
do anything special there.
It's like, it's the same,
it's whatever the repository
that you're fetching
the libraries from,
however it behaves.
It's probably going to get
the latest in that case.
AUDIENCE: So as new
VMs are spun up,
they may have newer versions.
So you'll have differences.
BRIAN DORSEY: So full circle,
we should update the demo
to conclude the version.
AUDIENCE:Could you comment on
what the experience is going
to be for the developer in terms
of debt server and managed VMs.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yes.
So again, I could go into it,
I would suggest you check out
the 2:30 session,
Runtime Yours, they're
going to talk about ways
that we can make that happen.
Because it is a
very intrinsic issue
in how you want to
handle it because you've
got dependencies and
things like that.
Containers actually
play into that as well.
And some of the technologies
evolving in the market today.
We're looking at how
we can leverage those.
And again, we can do some
foreshadowing in that session.
I don't want to
just [INAUDIBLE],
but it's a pretty
deep, deep answer.
We had somebody in
the back, I think.
I think this might
be the last question.
AUDIENCE: So on performance, so
great, perfect last question.
Performance related.
Do you envision any
future extensions or APIs
for doing things for high
performance computing.
For instance, pinning
threads to cores
to optimize L3 cash
management, understanding
what's happening
at the lower levels
mechanical sympathy
kind of programming.
NAVNEET JONEJA:So I don't have
any specific details to share.
But I just want to say that
HPC is a very world code to us.
We're definitely looking at
what we can do to make it work
as well as possible
on Compute Engine.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Anybody else?
We have 50 seconds.
49, 48, 47.
One more right here.
AUDIENCE: I know there's like a
big emphasis on Git and GitHub.
Is there any support
for subservsion?
JOE BEDA: So the question was,
Git and GitHub are great, what
about the subversion?
I don't know the answer to that.
NAVNEET JONEJA: We don't
have anything to say on that.
Sorry
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I think I
can see a guy in the back
that I can connect you with
that might have an answer.
NAVNEET JONEJA: I
think we're out.
CHRIS RAMSDALE:
Thanks for coming.
Thanks for watching online.